so here's a question for you when the
coronavirus vaccine becomes available
do you plan to take it some of you
watching will say
absolutely yes others will say you're
not sure
and still others will say absolutely not
there's no way
well the truth is for those of you who
are unsure or those of you who say no
yale university is working on a study to
make sure they know how to properly
manipulate you
into actually taking the vaccine not
kidding about this the study
is being created to figure out different
ways
to message or persuade americans
to take the vaccine when it becomes
available and some of what
that particular study is looking at will
probably infuriate you
i'm ben swann and this is truth in media
there's been a lot of talk about the
covid19 vaccine that of course isn't
even on the market yet and yet
when the world's most rushed vaccine
does finally make it to the public and
sooner or later it will the question
becomes how many people will
actually line up to take it now this is
a question that is frustrating
governments
and certainly vaccine makers and people
like bill gates and dr anthony fauci
who want to make sure that the entire
american population
does receive the vaccine the problem is
even with the current flu vaccine
about half of the country never bothers
to get it so how do you convince people
to get the coronavirus vaccine and
that's where yale university has stepped
in before we get to
the findings of how their study is being
conducted
let's give a shout out to our sponsor
ise.media our new free speech platform
being created
for content creators and those who think
outside
of this current paradigm and to allow
people to have a different thought
than the ones being permitted right now
by social media companies and by the way
we're running
an equity crowdfunding raise to make
this happen
you can get it on the ground floor
become an investor with
ise.media you can actually own a piece
of this free speech network again
it's ise.media all right so let's talk
about this yale study which has just
been leaked
that is being done at yale university
and the goal of this study
of about 4 000 participants is being
done with
one purpose how to convince americans to
take the coronavirus vaccine
now keep in mind the coronavirus vaccine
that's out front that most seems likely
to get to market first
is one being created by moderna
alongside the national institutes of
health
bill gates is a funder in this dr
anthony fauci obviously with his nih is
a big part of this
and remember of course moderna for their
part has never actually brought a drug
any drug
ever all the way through fda regulations
and trials
to get a drug to market they've never
done it and yet they are the company
leading the way on this brand new
coronavirus vaccine
so yale university researchers are now
looking at a 4 000 person study to try
to figure out
how to best create messaging though the
right term really should be
manipulation to persuade americans to
take this vaccine
when it does come to market the study
tests different messages about
vaccinating against covid19 once the
vaccine becomes available
participants are randomized to one of
twelve arms with one control arm and one
baseline arm
we will compare the reported willingness
to get a covid19 vaccine at three and
six months
of it becoming available between the tin
intervention arms
to the two control arms study
participants are recruited online by
lucid
which matches census-based sampling in
online recruitment
so take a look here at the arms and
interventions
they use a sham comparator control a
control message about bird feeding
2 out of 15 of the sample will be
assigned to the pure control group which
is
a passage on the costs and benefits of
bird feeding
under that are the experimental
comparators for instance the
experimental
personal freedom one fifteens of the
sample will be assigned to this
intervention which is a message about
how covid19
is limiting people's personal freedom
and by working together to get enough
people vaccinated
society can preserve its personal
freedom which of course makes no sense
at all
you will have personal freedom if you
comply and do what everyone else is
doing
regardless of how you feel about it
another experimental
social pressure through guilt one
fifteenth of the sample will be assigned
to this message
the message is about the danger that
covid19 presents to the health of one's
family and community
the best way to protect them is by
getting vaccinated and society must work
together to get enough people vaccinated
then it asks the participant to imagine
the guilt they will feel
if they don't get vaccinated and spread
the disease
another social pressure they want to use
embarrassment
one fifteenth of the sample will be
assigned to this message the message is
about the danger that covid19 presents
to the health of one's family and
community the best way to protect them
is by getting vaccinated and by working
together
to make sure that enough people get
vaccinated then it asks the participant
to imagine the embarrassment they will
feel
if they don't get vaccinated and spread
the disease
then they're trying to use the social
pressure anger
one fifteenth of the sample will be
assigned to this message the message is
about the danger that covid19 presents
to the health of one's family and
community
the best way to protect them is by
getting vaccinated and by working
together to make sure
that enough people get vaccinated then
it asks the participant to imagine the
anger they will feel
if they don't get vaccinated and spread
the disease
now here's my favorite one trust in
science
1 15 of the sample will be assigned to
this message about how getting
vaccinated against covid19
is the most effective way of protecting
one's community
vaccination is backed by science if one
doesn't get vaccinated that means that
one doesn't understand how infections
are spread
or who ignores science trust in science
they say is not based upon
trusting the fact that by the way not
all vaccinations work for all people
and by the way even the flu vaccine
that is taken by millions of people
every year
only affects 60 to 40 percent of those
who actually
get the vaccine we'll talk about more
about that in a minute because the cdc's
own numbers show only 40 to 60 percent
of the people
who take the flu vaccine actually have
benefit from it
and finally the experimental not bravery
arm
one fifteenth of the sample will be
assigned to this message which describes
how firefighters
doctors and frontline medical workers
are brave
those who choose not to get vaccinated
against covet 19
are not brave what are we five years old
you're going to try to convince people
to take the vaccine
by calling them scared you're too scared
to take this vaccine
by the way many of the people who would
refuse to take the vaccine
it's not about a lack of bravery it's
about a courage
of conviction and that conviction is
that they don't trust
how this vaccine is being manufactured
or the profit motivations
behind it that's not about cowardice
it's about courage of conviction
but going on from there microsoft
co-founder bill gates has said that
people could need
multiple doses of a potential
coronavirus vaccine to immunize
themselves from the coronavirus
if necessary the multiple doses could
require more than 7 billion vaccinations
to be administered
worldwide and of course all the
manipulation in this yell study
does not take into account the fact that
actually as i said
with the flu vaccine it is not always
effective and from year to year
who it's effective on and how it's
effective changes dramatically
in fact in 2012 to 2013 the h3n2
component of the flu vaccine was
effective
in just 39 of people
researchers from the university of
chicago harvard university and others
show
that poor immune responses may explain
the low effectiveness
of the vaccine that year and by the way
even the cdc admits that on
any given year only about 40 to 60
percent of the population actually
benefits from the vaccine that they have
taken
the flu vaccine can reduce the risk of
flu illness by between 40 and 60 percent
among the overall population
during seasons when most circulating flu
viruses
are well matched to the flu vaccine
you notice that wording there when it is
well matched the reason for that is
because on any given year
vaccine makers make a vaccine for the
wrong flu strain they don't know which
flu strain
is going to be especially predominant so
there are millions of people who can
take vaccines
and have it for the wrong flu strain in
any given year
again the idea of what yale is pushing
here is that if you
trust science if you are brave if you
are a good person a compassionate person
a person who cares about
their family and their neighbors you
will do this
you will take this vaccine because by
taking the vaccine
everyone is safer and yet the simple
basic
science of vaccines even if you believe
completely in vaccines we're not even
going to debate
about the side effects of vaccines even
if you believe that they
absolutely work no side effects
the reality is even by the cdc's own
numbers
they're only effective on any given year
in 40 to 60 percent
of the population that takes them but
the real reason for this yell study is
because even with the flu vaccine
less than half of the u.s population
actually takes that vaccine
on any given year and that is the number
that big pharma is afraid of that bill
gates is afraid of that anthony fauci
that half of americans won't take a flu
vaccine
and it's likely that even fewer will be
willing to take
their coronavirus vaccine
you